.
* Dumpfer Aufprall *
Man muss gegen den Wind zielen,
um die Mulde zu treffen.
Wenn ich gegen vorne zielte,
kam es immer zurück.
Die Vision ist gross:
Der Wasserturm von Cuxhaven
soll komplett umgebaut werden,
im Wassertank ein Café entstehen.
Das Ehepaar Caboussat
hofft auf die Unterstützung der Stadt
und hatte eine Sitzung
mit dem Oberbürgermeister.
Wir sind froh, dass Sie da sind.
Zudem bauten sie ihren Vintage-
Citroën zu einem Kaffeemobil um.
Die Kaffeemühle kommt hierhin.
Wenn ich mich bücke, muss genug
Platz für mein Hinterteil bleiben.
Das sind 40 cm.
Über ein Jahr ist es her,
seit sich das Ehepaar Schommer
von der Schweiz und ihrem Sohn Dylan
verabschiedet hat.
In Ruanda
bauten sie ein Fitnessstudio auf.
Wegen Corona verschiebt sich dessen
Eröffnung aber auf unbestimmte Zeit.
Das Ehepaar ist deprimiert.
Wir überlegen uns, ob Dianne
zurück in die Schweiz soll,
damit sie wenigstens
Dylan wiedersehen kann.
Ja, oder du.
Ein Hundehotel in Spanien.
Das Projekt von Corinne und Ralf
Waldburger kommt nicht auf Touren.
Neben der Bürokratie
erschwert auch der Nachbar ihr Leben.
Man schiesst über die Medien
gegen uns,
anstatt an einen Tisch zu sitzen
und zu reden.
Bis die
langersehnte Baubewilligung kommt,
sucht Ralf
eine neue Einnahmequelle.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
# Uf u dervo.
Es ist bereits
die zweite Weihnachtszeit,
die unsere Thurgauer Auswanderer in
ihrer neuen Heimat Spanien erleben.
Die Zeit vergeht -
und doch
scheint alles stillzustehen.
Während des ganzen vergangenen Jahres
mussten sich die Schweizer
in Geduld üben.
Nichts lief wie erwünscht.
Besonders Corinnes Liebstem, Ralf,
schlug dieses Nichtstun aufs Gemüt.
Auch das kleine Poolhaus konnten
sie wegen Corona nicht vermieten.
Im Moment geht es ihm wieder besser,
aber eine Zeit lang
machte ich mir Sorgen,
weil er ganz anders war.
Er war immer bedrückt ...
... und schlief schlecht.
Wir fühlten uns
wie in einem Hamsterrad,
weil nichts ging.
Wir sagten uns jetzt,
dass wir uns auch Zeit
für die schöne Dinge nehmen müssen -
z.B. mal ans Meer sitzen.
Damit auch das wieder Platz hat.
Das Warten auf die Baubewilligung
ist zermürbend.
An dieser Front
zeichnet sich ein Lichtblick ab,
unverändert schlecht aber ist
Waldburgers Verhältnis zum Nachbarn.
Noch immer
ist seine Haltung feindlich.
* Melancholische Gitarrenklänge *
Trotz mehrmaligen Versuchen
schafften sie es nicht,
den spanischen Nachbarn
für ein Gespräch zu gewinnen.
Damit sie ihm
ihr Projekt vorstellen können.
Ich mache ein Herz
aus diesen Steinen.
Für wen?
Trotz Hindernissen und Ärger:
Corinne will sich das Leben
nicht schwer machen.
Sie besitzt das einzigartige Talent,
Problemen spielerisch zu begegnen.
Momentan legt uns unser Nachbar
diese Steine in den Weg,
weil er gegen unser Hundehotel ist.
Sein Verhalten ist unsympathisch.
Und: Wenn man aus den Steinen,
die einen in den Weg gelegt werden,
ein Herz macht,
ist das schön und erfreut einem.
Es ist so schön hier,
das lassen wir uns nicht nehmen.
Sie nimmt alles viel lockerer -
und sieht das Ganze von
einer anderen Perspektive als ich.
Denn ich sehe manchmal alles zu eng.
Einen Grund zur Hoffnung
gibt es nun endlich:
Das Gesuch
ist bei fast allen Ämtern durch.
Zur Überwindung der letzten Hürde
treffen sich die Waldburgers
mit ihrem Anwalt.
Um die Baubewilligung
für ihre Hundepension zu erhalten,
mussten sie den Behörden
ein Konzept einreichen.
Ein Christbaum.
Das ist schon mehr als ein Jahr her.
Die Päckchen
sehen etwas verschandelt aus.
200 Seiten lang war das Konzept.
Nun fehlt einzig und allein
noch das Okay des Veterinäramtes.
Diesem Amt
ist ihr Konzept aber zu detailliert.
Jetzt, nach über einem Jahr,
heisst es von der letzten Stelle,
die das Okay geben müsste,
dass das, was wir eingegeben haben,
zu umfangreich sei.
Also ein zu grosses Dossier.
Das mussten wir nun
auf eine kleinere Version anpassen.
Wir hoffen,
dass diese nun in Ordnung ist.
Damit es vorwärtsgeht
und wir endlich
eine positive Nachricht erhalten.
Genau.
Gemeinsam mit dem Anwalt werden sie
eine schlankere Version einreichen.
Die Chancen stehen gut,
dass diese Version
schneller das ersehnte
und letzte Okay bekommen wird.
Bei der Auswandererfamilie Caboussat
in Cuxhaven
dreht sich seit über zwei Jahren
alles um ihren Wasserturm.
Nun haben sie eine
tiefgreifende Entscheidung getroffen:
Es gibt kein Café im Wassertank oben,
40 m hoch über der Stadt.
Die Emmentaler wollen
ihr Projekt radikal verkleinern.
Die vielen Vorschriften, die
Verzögerungen und dann noch Corona.
Mirabelle und Alain mussten
ihre ursprünglichen Pläne aufgeben.
Hast du den Baubeschrieb gefunden?
Ja. Es gibt da ein paar Dinge,
die wir anschauen müssen.
Das Vorhaben wurde immer teurer -
zu teuer für ihr Budget.
Wir sind ein Start-up.
Wir können
nicht einfach Kredite aufnehmen,
da wir die Reserven nicht haben
oder später erwirtschaften können.
Die Brandschutzauflagen
und Hochhausrichtlinien
wurden so umfassend und aufwendig,
dass wir merkten,
dass wir
eine andere Lösung finden müssen.
Das bedeutet,
dass wir hier unten das Café machen.
Hier geht es ins erste Obergeschoss,
das ist die erste Ferienwohnung.
Im zweiten dann die zweite.
Die dritte Ferienwohnung
liegt unter dem Technikbereich.
Das Café im Erdgeschoss also.
Der Umbau des Wassertanks
ist somit hinfällig.
Und auch ein Grossteil
der Brandschutzauflagen.
Den Tank wollen sie jedoch
der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen.
Schon bald wollen sie das
redimensionierte Gesuch einreichen.
Als Berner
sind wir langsam und gelassen.
Wir nehmen es so, wie es kommt.
Genau.
* Ruhige Xylofonklänge *
In Kigali, der Hauptstadt Ruandas,
steht unseren Afrika-Auswanderern
ein besonderer Abend bevor.
Heute treffen sie
nach über einem Jahr ihren Sohn.
Dylan spielt in der ruandischen
Basketball-Nationalmannschaft.
Wegen der Qualifikationsspiele
für die afrikanische Meisterschaft
ist er nach Kigali gereist.
Hello, how are you?
Kontakte mit der Aussenwelt
durfte Dylan bisher nicht haben.
Doch die Schommers
dürfen ein Training besuchen.
Noch müssen sie einen Moment warten.
Wow, VIP.
Bald sehen sie ihren Sohn -
von Weitem.
(Englisch)
Rutsch ein Stück.
Ich kann nicht nicht hochspringen.
Es ist okay, Schatz.
Ja, ja. Ist gut.
* Rhythmische Klänge *
Sehen: ja, umarmen: nein.
Corona
ist einmal mehr Spielverderber.
Die dritte rechts.
Der 203 cm grosse Dylan
trägt die Nummer 7.
Wenn das Training beendet ist,
schreien wir.
Ich kann nicht schreien.
Sie machen sicher mal Pause,
dann kann er hierhin kommen.
Dann können wir
wenigstens hier Hallo sagen.
Weiss du, hier unten.
That's not the problem.
Okay.
Dylan ist in der Schweiz Semiprofi
und als Doppelbürger in der ruan-
dischen Nationalmannschaft engagiert.
(Flüsternd) Dylan.
Seine Eltern
hat er noch nicht entdeckt.
* Marco lacht. *
Jetzt hat er uns gesehen.
Dylan wird zurückgepfiffen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Schweizerdeutsch)
Gib alles.
Love you, Dylan.
Tschüss.
Erst nach dem morgigen Spiel dürfen
sie sich in die Arme schliessen.
Noch 24 Std.
Ich verstehe es schon, ja.
Aber eben ...
Die Traurigkeit ist da.
Wenigstens
konnten wir ihn näher sehen.
Er hat ein neues Tattoo, by the way.
* Marco lacht. *
Kein Kommentar.
- Kein Kommentar.
Er hat mich nicht gefragt. Normaler-
weise fragt er mich immer.- Okay.
Erneut bekommt Alain
die Folgen der Pandemie zu spüren.
Eigentlich
verdient der Familienvater das Geld
mit der Organisation von Messen
in der Schweiz.
Eine Grossveranstaltung
ist nun verschoben worden.
* Heitere Klänge *
Deshalb hat Alain
jetzt ausgiebig Zeit.
Seit Tagen schon
entkernt er den Turm.
Der gelernte Sanitärinstallateur
reisst von Badewanne bis Küche
alles heraus und schlägt
den jahrzehntealten Verputz ab.
* Leises Hämmern *
Hoi, Schatz.
Hoi.
Du bist richtig weit oben.
Was machst du gerade?
Ich löse den Verputz.
An dieser Ecke muss ich
nichts machen, die kommt raus.
Hier wird neu verputzt.
Danach ...
Vieles lassen wir ja
wie im Original.
Im Endeffekt
mache ich das sehr gerne.
Es geht auch darum ...
... dass ich
Energie rauslassen kann.
Das ist in Zeiten von Corona
etwas schwierig,
deshalb tut mir das gut.
* Heitere Klänge *
Neuigkeiten vom Oberbürgermeister
haben die Caboussats
noch keine erhalten.
Aber der Denkmalschutz gab
nun endlich eine erste Einwilligung.
Ich sagte: "Jetzt ist fertig,
wir müssen einfach loslegen."
Wir haben der Denkmalbehörde
ein kurzes Statement geschrieben,
dass wir loslegen.
Das haben wir ihnen so mitgeteilt,
dann gaben sie ihre Einwilligung.
Wir dürfen ausräumen,
was sehr wichtig ist.
Okay.
Ich möchte die Sachen nachher nicht
in der Gegend einsammeln müssen.
Ich schliesse den Deckel.
Das ist eine gute Idee, sonst liegt
draussen alles verstreut herum.
* Dumpfer Aufprall *
Getroffen hast du. Und?
Gut. Aber die Kiste ist kaputt.
Das war klar. Hey, super. So
haben wir ein paar Tritte gespart.
Man muss gegen den Wind zielen,
um die Mulde zu treffen.
Jetzt ist es windstill, so geht's.
Aber letzte Woche ...
Wenn ich gegen vorne zielte,
kam es immer zurück.
Nicht nur Bauschutt.
Es scheint, Alain befreie sich auch
von angestautem Frust.
So kriegt man
einen dreckigen Hintern.
Was gibt's?
- Käsewurst mit Pommes.
Lecker, danke.
Endlich.
Endlich geht es vorwärts.
Auch Ralf ist während
des langen Wartens nicht untätig.
Er hat eine Firma gegründet:
Waldburger Swiss-Homeservice.
Neu will er
Immobilien bewirtschaften.
Und er hat bereits
einen ersten Auftrag.
Wir schalteten Inserate
in der "Costa Blanca Nachrichten".
Ein Herr
meldete sich auf das Inserat -
so sind wir
zu diesem Auftrag gekommen.
Weil er im Moment
aufgrund von COVID
leider nicht
nach Spanien reisen kann,
haben wir einen Termin mit
dem jetzigen Betreuer dieses Hauses.
Morgens herrscht hier jeweils Chaos.
Ironie des Schicksals:
Eigentlich wollen die Waldburgers
in ihrer Pension Hunde betreuen.
Heute müssen sie jedoch
ihren Hund, Benji, abgeben.
Statt Vierbeiner
betreuen sie nun Liegenschaften.
Hola!
Buenos dias.
Benji, wo sind wir?
Corinnes Eltern
passen derweil auf den Kleinen auf.
Das Ehepaar Amherd lebt
seit 15 Jahren im sonnigen Spanien.
Und sie sind immer da,
wenn sie gebraucht werden.
Ich habe das Raubtier
bereits angekettet.
Gut.
Man konnte voraussehen,
dass es harzig wird.
Aber es ist nicht unüberwindbar.
Zum Glück haben sie gut vorgesorgt.
Finanziell ist es so,
dass sie es überbrücken können.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass sie es meistern werden.
Sie sind jung
und unternehmungslustig.
Wenn es
mit dem einen Projekt nicht klappt,
packen sie ein anderes an.
Ich glaube, das wird schon.
Es wird funktionieren.
Super.
Tschüss! Benimm dich gut.
Die guten Worte geben
den beiden Jungauswanderern Kraft
und stärken deren Durchhaltewillen.
Tschüss!
Ruanda gegen Südsudan -
heute findet in Kigali ein
wichtiges Qualifikationsspiel statt.
* Beschwingte Hip-Hop-Musik *
Dianne ist aufgeregt.
* Ruandische Nationalhymne *
* Horn *
* Dianne schreit. *
Nein! Also ehrlich ...
* Jemand jubelt. *
* Sie jubeln. *
Dylan gibt alles.
Trotzdem: Südsudan gewinnt.
Das Spiel war super.
Ich hatte Freude.
Das Problem ist:
Sie haben nicht gewonnen.
Aber mein Sohn hat gespielt.
Er hat gespielt,
das freut mich so.
Juhu!
Sowieso - das Schönste kommt noch.
Hey!
Wo ist Dylan?
I don't ... Ah!
There. Dylan!
Oh Baby.
* Marco schmunzelt. *
Es hat so lange gedauert.
Endlich sehen wir ihn wieder,
den Mzungu.
* Sie lachen. *
Come on.
Karibu, wie man hier sagt.
Welcome, Dylan, in unserem Haus.
Alle drei.
Endlich zusammen -
aber morgen Mittag schon muss Dylan
wieder zurück in die Schweiz.
Auch die Caboussats sind happy.
Ihr Kaffeemobil ist nach einem halben
Sommer Umbau endlich startklar.
Mit dem Cafélino auf drei Rädern
haben sie angefangen.
Auf Märkten
verkauften sie Schweizer Süssigkeiten
und schenkten Kaffee aus.
Ich habe ihn etwas anders ein-
gestellt. Warte, der Kaffeelöffel.
Der neue, umgebaute Citroën
bietet mehr Platz,
schützt gegen Wind und Kälte
und kommt bedeutend eleganter daher.
Auch Caboussats Kaffee ist exklusiv:
Sie haben eine eigene Mischung.
So ist es gar nicht schlecht.
Diese Einstellung ist gut,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Er ist gut.
Daraus machen wir einen Cappuccino.
Mal schauen, was dann passiert.
Sonst müssen wir es manuell machen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob sie es erkennt.
Der kultige Kleintransporter
aus den 70er-Jahren
ist eine kleine, aber wichtige
Einnahmequelle für die Familie ...
Unsere Spezialitäten.
... und das perfekte Werbevehikel
für ihr Turmprojekt.
Wirklich gut.
Es macht mega Spass,
ich freue mich sehr.
Es ist wieder ein Schritt
hin zum Wasserturm.
Alles zielt auf den Wasserturm ab.
Wenn wir nun ...
... die Leute
mit Kaffee beglücken können,
haben wir das Projekt
mit dem Kaffeemobil geschafft.
Prost!
* Mirabelle lacht. *
Es war der über 120 Jahre alte
Wasserturm mit seinem Potenzial,
der Familie Caboussat
zum Auswandern inspirierte.
Seit über zwei Jahren
wohnen sie an der Nordsee.
Ein Lebensabenteuer
für die ganze Familie.
Wir sind angekommen,
weil wir als Familie hier sind.
Alleine wäre es schwieriger.
Zu zweit oder zu viert -
wie bei uns - geht es gut.
Doch, wir sind angekommen.
Wir haben
viele nette Leute kennengelernt,
bei denen wir das Gefühl haben,
dass sie uns
und was wir tun schätzen.
Wir werden oft eingeladen -
das ist schön.
Wir freuen uns sehr ...
... auf diesen Turm ...
... und auf die Kaffeebar,
das ist cool.
Auch, damit wieder
etwas in die Kasse kommt, sonst ...
Ja.
Wir wollen nicht die Reserven
anzapfen, sondern möglichst ...
... von den Einnahmen leben können.
Die Reserven resp. das Ersparte
sind für den Wasserturm gedacht.
Du ...
Ohne Socken?
Ja.
Hallo.
Hello, was geht?
Der jüngere der beiden Söhne,
Yannis, ist im letzten Schuljahr.
Du hast Gemüse, Yannis.
Er möchte eine Ausbildung
als Forstwart beginnen.
Der 18-jährige Nicolas absolviert
eine Lehre als Hotelfachmann.
Bald schon
werden die Jungs ausfliegen.
Ist eine mit Ovomaltine und Nutella?
- Ja.
Vielen Dank, Schatz.
Guten Appetit.
Der Turm
bleibt das Projekt der Eltern.
Ich glaube, dass unsere Jungs ...
... selber entscheiden,
was sie machen möchten.
Ich möchte in die Schweiz zurück
und das Militär absolvieren.
Damit das erledigt ist.
Danach schaue ich weiter.
Man darf nicht etwas aufbauen
mit dem Gedanken,
dass es die Kinder
später übernehmen.
Das ist der falsche Weg.
Jeder soll sein Ding machen.
Evtl. kommen sie zurück
und finden es cool.
Falls nicht,
ist es einfach unser Ding.
Dann müssen wir weiterschauen -
das kann gut sein.
* Entspannte Klaviermusik *
Die Costa Blanca ist seit Jahrzehnten
ein beliebtes Urlaubsziel.
Viele Mitteleuropäer
besitzen hier ein Ferienhaus.
Eines davon werden nun
die Waldburgers betreuen dürfen.
Lass uns mal schauen.
Gut, dass es hier kein Glatteis hat.
* Corinne schmunzelt. *
Guten Morgen.
- Hallo.
Hallo, freut mich.
Der Pool
wird gerade nochmals geputzt.
Während Jahren
hat das deutsche Ehepaar Schnieber
diese Liegenschaft betreut.
Gehen wir zum Pool.
Klar.
Altershalber geben sie das Mandat ab.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Mitten in der Arbeit.
Bei einem solch schönen Arbeitsplatz
ist das wunderbar.
Lieber hier arbeiten
als im Büro vor dem PC.
Schön.
* Heitere Gitarrenklänge *
Peter Schnieber zeigt den beiden
Thurgauern die künftigen Aufgaben.
Das ist der Wohnbereich.
Man muss also immer,
bevor sie kommen ...
... sauber machen und abstauben.
Genau.
Sie melden sich meist vorher an.
Sie sagen, wann
und mit vielen Leuten sie kommen.
Die Betten
müssen hergerichtet werden.
Super. Das ist ja kein Problem.
Nein.
Hier hinten
ist ein kleiner Wintergarten.
Wir stellen meist
die Schirme und Liegen raus.
Und ein paar Stühle
vorne beim Tisch.
Damit alles bereit ist,
wenn sie kommen.
Genau. Damit sie wenig Arbeit haben,
wenn sie Urlaub machen.
Dafür gehen sie in den Urlaub.
Das ist der Pool.
Werfen wir einen Blick ins Poolhaus.
Ja.
Wahnsinnig, wie hier
alles in den Berg gebaut ist.
Ja.
Ralf ist ein Mann
mit grossem handwerklichem Geschick.
Der gelernte Autolackierer
baute einst sein Haus in der Schweiz
eigenhändig um.
Ich bin richtig -
wie soll ich sagen -
begierig, etwas zu tun.
Nicht nur bei mir zu Hause,
sondern auch anderen
etwas Gutes zu tun
und deren Haus zu betreuen.
Da bin ich richtig ... ready.
Gut.
So.
Super.
Vielen lieben Dank.
Nichts zu danken.
Wir übernehmen das gerne.
Ich wünsche euch viel Erfolg.
Vielen lieben Dank.
Sehr schön.
Wir sehen und hören uns.
Ruf an,
wenn du Probleme oder Fragen hast.
Das ist lieb.
Super, vielen Dank. Tschüss!
- Tschüss.
Der Hausbesitzer
hat ein Grundpaket gebucht.
D.h. eine wöchentliche Kontrolle
von Haus und Pool,
Lüften und Pflanzen giessen.
Weitere Arbeiten
kann Ralf zusätzlich verrechnen.
Das ist super, oder?
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Ich denke, man könnte davon leben.
Aber man braucht natürlich ...
... ein Paar Liegenschaften.
Mit einer oder zwei
ist es nicht getan.
Über den Daumen gerechnet,
mit den Preisen vor Ort -
braucht man sicher
ca. zehn Liegenschaften,
um hier überleben
bzw. leben zu können.
Ich freue mich sehr, dass wir
unseren ersten Auftrag haben.
Und ...
V.a., weil in der Zeit davor
gar nichts lief,
und auch mit dem Hundehotel
nichts läuft.
Deshalb freue ich mich sehr,
dass Ralf seinen ersten Auftrag hat.
Das ist super,
es ist ein schöner Arbeitsplatz.
Trotzdem muss man hier arbeiten.
- Natürlich.
Der Unterhalt von Ferienhäusern -
ein Geschäft,
das sich auch während dem Bau
ihres Hundehotels fortführen liesse.
In Kigali neigt sich ein Workshop
zum Thema Kundenservice dem Ende zu.
Ein Berufsverband
hat dazu eingeladen.
Dank seines Wissens
und seiner Kontakte
ist Marco der Leiter des Anlasses.
(Englisch)
* Applaus *
Thank you.
Der Maschineningenieur
hofft auf weitere Workshops,
nicht nur des Geldes wegen.
Die Arbeit hilft ihm,
hier Fuss zu fassen.
Ich habe noch immer
ein wenig das Gefühl ...
... jetzt von der Schweiz
weg zu sein, das sicher.
Aber ich bin noch nicht
zu 100 % angekommen.
Es ist seltsam
und schwierig zu erklären.
Was immer noch fehlt,
ist das komplette soziale Netzwerk
im Umfeld.
Ich hoffe, es ist bald so weit,
dass ich sagen kann:
"Ich bin hier mehr zu Hause
als irgendwo anders."
* Rhythmische Trommelklänge *
Schon vor der Auswanderung
wusste Marco,
dass sie von den Einnahmen
des Fitnessstudios allein
nicht leben können.
Vor wenigen Monaten haben sie deshalb
auf einem 3,5 ha grossen
Landstück Zitronengras angepflanzt.
Heute ist Erntetag.
Zitronengras kann mehrere Male
im Jahr geschnitten werden.
Das freie Feld hat seine Tücken.
(Englisch)
You see?
- Oh Gott.
* Sie lachen. *
15 Leute ernten während drei Tagen.
Marco will nicht nur genau wissen,
wie viele Kilogramm die Ernte wiegt,
er ist auch einer,
der gerne selbst anpackt.
Oh.
* Sie lachen. *
Give me another one.
Oh no.
10 t Zitronengras kann Marco
an einen Duftölproduzenten verkaufen.
Da der Zitrusgehalt des Grases
nicht besonders hoch ist,
ist der Erlös eher bescheiden.
Trotzdem -
einige Hundert Dollar gibt es.
Fahr etwas zurück,
damit wir auf dem Weg stehen.
Oder sogar etwas abdrehen.
Nein, andersrum.
Andersrum, so.
Die Leute kommen von da oder da.
Wir wollen doch nicht
so schräg stehen,
sondern so,
damit uns die Leute besser sehen.
Die Leute kommen von da.
- Deshalb müssen wir doch so stehen.
Im Dezember kommt das Café Wasserturm
zu seinem ersten Einsatz.
Am alten Hafen
findet ein Kultur-Event statt.
Lange bevor die Veranstaltung
beginnt, sind die Caboussats vor Ort.
Abdrehen, nein, stopp.
Corona und garstiges Wetter - Alain
zweifelt am Erfolg des Anlasses.
Wenn ich das so anschaue ...
... sind wir ganz alleine.
Ob das wirklich das ist,
was wir wollten?
Aber eben -
wenn wir es nicht versuchen,
klappt es sowieso nicht.
Mirabelle lässt sich nicht beirren.
Charmant knüpft sie Kontakte.
Das ist ein Oldtimer.
Trotz wenigen Besuchern
bei ihrem Citroën HY -
Erfahrungen
sammeln die beiden allemal.
Wir sind immer noch glücklich,
das heisst viel.
Mit der Maschine und allem -
es macht Freude und ist gut.
So haben wir etwas mehr zu tun.
Hier oben gibt es keine HY,
die sind verrostet
oder kamen nie bis hierher.
Mmh.
Ja, die sind lecker, die Törtli.
Das ist eine Bündner Nusstorte,
typisch schweizerisch -
mit Walnüssen und Caramel,
sehr lecker.
Hallo, moin.
- Hallo.
Was gibt's denn hier?
Oh, Eierpunsch.
Ich hätte gerne einen Lumumba.
Gerne.
- Einen Lumumba ...
Sie klingen wie ein Schweizer.
Genau. Wir wohnen schon
seit zweieinhalb Jahren hier.
Und ... wir wollen
den Wasserturm umbauen.
Ich wollt grad sagen:
der Wasserturm.
Die Idee geht auf:
Das Gespräch führt augenblicklich
zu ihrem grossen Herzensprojekt,
dem Wasserturm.
Das ist wichtig,
denn Alain zählt nicht nur
auf die Unterstützung der Stadt,
sondern auch auf deren Bewohner.
Wir arbeiten momentan am Sponsoring.
Wir wollen Pflastersteine
ins Leben rufen,
Fenster und Treppenstufen verkaufen,
damit wir es gut finanzieren können.
Die Finanzierung
ist ein grosser Brocken.
Wir hoffen, Leute zu finden,
denen diese Idee gefällt
und die das unterstützen.
Das ist der Wunsch.
Wir bleiben weiterhin dran -
auch wenn wir
noch nicht so weit sind.
Wir werden unser Ziel erreichen.
Das Ziel ist, dass die Leute denken:
"Wenn du in Cuxhaven bist,
musst du bei denen vorbeischauen -
da gibt es den besten Kaffee."
Das streben wir an.
Hindernisse sind dafür da,
überwunden zu werden.
Die Caboussats nehmen jeden Rück-
schlag als neue Herausforderung an
und nähern sich so stetig
ihrem grossen Ziel.
In Ruanda sind die Schommers eigent-
lich schon lange auf der Zielgeraden.
Wegen Corona aber dürfen sie
ihr Studio noch immer nicht eröffnen.
Glücklicherweise macht der Vermieter
ihrer Fitnessräume keinen Druck mehr.
Solange das Studio geschlossen ist,
müssen sie keine Miete bezahlen.
Bars und Sportanlagen
werden wohl als Letzte geöffnet.
Es geht nur langsam vorwärts -
aber ich hoffe schwer,
das wir bald dran sind.
Okay.
Sie nutzen die Zeit
und machen Fotos für ihre Website.
Let's go.
* Elektronische Tanzmusik *
Good.
Hey! Juhu, hey.
Jump, jump, jump.
Okay.
* Sie jubeln, Marco lacht. *
Okay, very good.
Alles okay - alles ...
Noch hat sich Diannes langerersehnter
Traum vom eigenen Fitnessstudio
nicht erfüllt.
Trotzdem: kein Grund zur Reue.
Ich würde nichts anders machen.
Wir haben gemacht,
was man machen konnte.
For me -
apart from COVID ...
Das hätte nicht sein müssen.
Aber sonst ...
würde ich nichts anders machen.
Ich wollte hierhin kommen,
um in meinem Leben etwas zu ändern.
Sonst hätte ich
im selben Trott weitergemacht.
So konnte ich
sehr viele neue Erfahrungen machen.
Einerseits die Selbstständigkeit -
die ... Jobsuche,
die Unsicherheit.
Anderseits konnte ich neue Leute
und v.a. neue Gebiete kennenlernen.
Doch, ich sehe es bisher
als lohnende Erfahrung.
Ich bereue es wirklich nicht.
Ich bereue es auch nicht.
Aber ...
Es ist noch nicht ...
Ja, es ist noch nicht top.
Genau,
aber ich bereue es auch nicht.
Es ist noch nicht top,
aber ... auf einem guten Weg.
Wieder auswandern?
Nein, ich bleibe hier.
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Mit Gelassenheit und Hüftschwung
akzeptieren die Schommers
ihre jetzige Situation -
und so werden sie auch
die Zukunft meistern.
Hey.
* Ruhige Gitarrenklänge *
Auch bei unseren Spanien-Auswanderern
lief vieles anders als gedacht.
Vor erst gut drei Jahren
lernten sich Corinne und Ralf kennen.
Ab dann ging alles rasant:
Heirat nach einem Jahr,
gemeinsames Auswandern nach zwei.
Und dann in Spanien: Stillstand.
Corona und all die Verzögerungen
schlagen aufs Gemüt.
Zusammen warten - diese Erfahrung
haben die beiden noch nicht gemacht.
Mañana, mañana ...
Das ist ...
sehr präsent bei den Spaniern.
Man hat uns wohl gesagt,
dass es
dieses "mañana, mañana" gibt.
Man hat uns aber auch gesagt,
dass es
nicht mehr so sei wie früher.
Aber ...
Es ist immer noch wie früher.
Diese Lebenseinstellung
muss man akzeptieren,
sonst -
da muss ich ehrlich sein -
hat man hier unten keine Chance.
Man muss auch sehr geduldig sein.
Wenigstens ist beim Warten
das Wetter schön, oder?
Es könnte auch regnen oder schneien.
- So ist es.
Ein Leben mit Sonne und Meer.
Einer der wenigen Träume,
die sich erfüllt haben
in diesem schwierigen Jahr.
Zeitweise war es ...
... auch bei uns nicht einfach.
Seit wir ausgewandert sind,
sind wir 24 Std. am Tag,
sieben Tage die Woche zusammen.
Klar, dass es da
Situationen und Momente gibt,
die weniger schön sind.
Ich denke aber ...
... dass unsere Liebe
das aushalten wird.
Oder, Schatz?
Unsere Liebe hält dies aus.
Ich hatte eine Weile
extrem zu kämpfen ...
... weil einfach ...
... nichts vorwärtsging.
Zu dieser Zeit ...
... hatten wir öfters mal
Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Und nasse Füsse.
Das Wichtigste ist,
dass wir immer noch lachen können.
Wenn das nicht mehr geht,
ist nicht mehr gut.
Genau.
* Beschwingte Gitarrenklänge *
So ein Sandstrand ist schon toll.
Das müssen wir öfter tun.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Désirée Häfeli - 2021